does this look on this look on the
healthy to you let's go feed some people
right I am holding back your gag reflex
probably getting close to four hundred
five hundred dollars an hour after we
have to get out of here on time there's
a lot of comments out there wondering
what's in that juice that I've been
drinking a lot lately is it healthy for
me or is it poisonous today you're gonna
find out secrets of the juice I found
the secrets of the juice they're in here
it's called drinking soda all the time
dick if you had to guess what what is it
you don't know I don't want a single I
don't want a single hint alright number
one it's got whey protein in it
vegetable extract a bunch of vegetables
boiled down into a powder it's got
different individual like beans and
seeds a core fruit that I'm forgetting
if I had to guess there's probably
cabbage grass some grass sunflower seeds
and bananas and probably kale because
that's like a really hip thing right now
I had five bananas oh that's the fruit I
was talking about kale cilantro parsley
some strawberries some raspberries
tumeric and then I put black pepper in
there to activate the tumeric dates
grounded flax seeds and not whey protein
powder but plant-based protein powder
because way is dairy is dairy right okay
this looks pretty good man this looks
like really fresh fruit protein mix
sounds pretty good actually
it's about 950 calories this isn't my
personal recipe I got this from simnet
nutrition Derek he's a youtuber he's a
vegan Cal aesthetics
he has 31 recipes vegan muscle hook if
you're interested go check it out it's
amazing stuff I eat all the stuff in
here would you say it's a great channel
if you're looking to become vegan if
you're interested in vegan going vegan
or just learning more about vegan and
then just Cal aesthetics he's also a
licensed nutritionist blend it up dude
[Music]
so yeah I have one of these after every
workout and I workout about five to six
times a week
[Music]
way to change your life you know I would
be open to that here we go I can water
it down a little bit Fred didn't expect
it to smell that fresh Wow
all right so Adrian has a very very
ambitious idea we've talked about it
already but to tomorrow it becomes a
real thing when we go to film it it's
intense man
preparing a movie is more important than
shooting it the more attention you can
place in pre-production the smoother
your feet will go I'm gonna be building
some homemade squibs I'm gonna let
Jarrett tell you guys how to do that
with household products slice up the
bottle and then grab a balloon around
the bottom to secure it with rubber
bands baby powder in there and then just
pop it the concrete wall 3 2 1 yeah easy
that's why things like this let's shot
lists under shot list after job you know
top down on the day the DP he will have
an idea including all the actors of like
what the day is gonna look like yeah
four pages a day usually is the max
we're doing six tomorrow and the day
after that I've got everyone that I can
pull from the studio not a Saturday
pulling favors from Thunder Studios it
would be cool to shoot here it's really
ambitious of you you shoot eleven pages
in two days yeah well this is an
ambitious piece there no one ever
learned anything by doing everything
right make mistakes so you learn I am
gonna get all of the pages then I can
confidently say that to put it Frank
we're out of money and we're out of time
dang it guys have you played Zelda in
the new Zelda where you go to this
island and then they take all your armor
and all your weapons away go they're
super high level you got best armor best
swords and suddenly they're just like
we're praying literally our entire light
inventory to cameras when you all eyes
mean all of them like it's huge huge
huge but like you got to be so good that
you have to be just to strip yourself
completely no lights no camera shooting
you have to be so good at making a video
that you shoot a video without even
having a camera we're talking like
that's the mindset you have to get into
into making youtube videos because you
have you have to make it with nothing
youtube blazing nothing for these videos
and that is the essence of filmmaking
tomorrow on set that is gonna be my
primary goal to make lightning happen
lightning strike magic I would drink
that I'm actually surprised actually not
that heavy drink let's go feed some
people who doesn't even know that this
coming you should try something
healthier it doesn't smell that bad
it smells like apples and carrots and
probably like parsley and junk like that
that's weird it's drinkable though for a
second one it's drinkable do you think
this little probably play soda for you
now definitely if you made it palatable
so congrats Congrats do you can chew it
I am holding back a gag reflex just a
little bit you can drink it or you could
like you can use this for like a chicken
pesto panini thank you thanks for the
taste
that pesto so this is the famous
Carmichael Jesus car Ren would you say
that it's drinkable
edible would you say that it's a
replacement for your sandwich right
there
no the sandwiches are the best Jenna
makes them hey I made you some juice
just for me just for you drink on this
side okay a lot of cilantro
it takes you pretty good I mean it sort
of just tastes like a smoothie but and I
have some more everyone is this one of
the best drinks you can have after a
workout or is it slowly killing us find
out in a few weeks subscribe
[Music]
big question of the day still remain 10
Adrienne execute on his ambitious vision
to shoot a 12 page very abstract
creative piece in just two days now so
far a critical step to him executing on
this has been getting the writing to
scale we've gotten the writing to scale
okay great we're right on the edge of
what's possible for the amount of time
and money that we have available but now
here on Sat Adrienne is figuring out how
to bring that photography to scale as
well dude I'm just trying to make the
day go easier there's no one really to
help on art it's kind of charit it's
doing sfx and art and making fake
license plates ten five cars so ten
total I don't know if cars in Maine have
front and rear actually Dobie put it on
cardboard put a little gap on there I'm
just trying to speed up where we can
right now it's to finish all the art for
the cars
check out this broken glass pretty great
right what's this well it's okay it's
rubber it's like a rubberized acrylic
material you buy it in shards or pains
you know but it's just sloppy it kind of
looks like jello but then you can just
rip it into broken glass pieces with the
plexi on to be the broken mirror we're
also putting broken glass and
everybody's safe there's no problem we
can you know you can roll on it
everything's great
yeah they look real it looks real one
challenge we're dealing with right now
the main source of light for the scene
Adrian wants to be a soft top down life
so we have this aperture 300d light
which we are going to try to hoist up
into the rafters and then suspend above
our scene with a aperture space light is
basically just a tubular softbox so
Spacey spooky before they place the life
they need to call Adrian over and he
talked to the DP and the grip teams who
talked about where this light is gonna
go but in order to do that you need to
know where the actors are going to be
blocked for
you get the blackk hey make anyone so
we're shooting it out of order or
shooting the ending first so we gotta
gotta wrap my head around that
yeah if we have a rope yeah we did we
brought our look well we should move the
car and try to feel it walk over it so
we can get up over the domicile shut up
I'm doing sound woman I'm boom boy
it's all about that part
right now we are starting the first
blocking which is great because it's
ten o'clock right now probably be
shooting in the next 30 minutes and that
gives us a page an hour it's that's a
little quick
yeah talk to me said wants to take time
to set up the first shop isn't what we
rollin how they're broke is in the shot
get up shot one it's looking pretty
ominous in here I'm actually pretty
happy without it looks now we just got
to make sure I can check off all these
boxes there's a lot of boxes to check
off before we have to get out here I
just read the be like location thing
there is there's some major overtime
charges 200 out $200 per hour after the
amount and then you have to also pay on
a dodge per hour for security and
stage-manager per hour after probably
getting close to four hundred five
hundred dollars an hour after our set
time so we have to get out of here on
time alright here's here's the real
people always ask me what I do at court
or what is my job
Operations Director is probably most
appropriate Sam's job and Nico's job is
there to come up with the most creative
things possible and execute on them my
job is to make sure that those things
happen so I need to know about a lot of
things and basically it
I'm a facilitator of a silicon red basic
what does that mean it means that I find
the best way for people to work together
and then wherever things aren't
happening I just fill in the gap like
that's my job so I need to know about
editing I need to know a little bit
about visual effects I need to know
about like how to put videos online I
need to know a little bit about like
framing and cinematography I need to
know a lot about business and contracts
it's how to structure projects and then
I kind of when it comes to actually
filming stuff I think they kind of be a
jack-of-all-trades I need to know about
how to put costumes together that makes
sense a saline explosions and all kinds
of nonsense and then I need to know a
little bit about acting and I need to
know a little bit about action then
stunts and all of that stuff because my
job is to say okay what is everyone
doing and how can I make all of the
parts fit together and if they're all
fitting together perfectly great then my
job is done and when they're not my job
is hell because it's my job to make sure
that every penny and is accounted for
and at the end of the day things are
going wrong and it's in the buck stops
at you here's the thing ultimately
Adrienne's doing this but if he if for
some reason I don't think he will but if
for some this is honest truth if I don't
think he will I think this is gonna be a
success because he's smart he knows
exactly what he's doing he knows exactly
what he wants I think it's gonna be
great but if for some reason it doesn't
go that way at the end of the day it's
not his fault
it's mine
so that's that's the real that's what it
comes down to a little behind but now
that things aren't moving
you should make up a little time and
what we're trying to do never come back
to the same lighting or camera angles
setup so we're saving time so instead of
going seen eight films intense scene 11
we're gonna go 8 10 12 from this side
will move the set up and then it's 8 10
and 12 from that set up it's kind of up
to Adrienne and I can just track and
make sure he's getting everything he
needs
Dork
that's great
[Music]
a Benelli said that the house if you can
do that your style at lights on the
corner but we got to do a house if these
house lights on them what's up okay okay
alright that's a wrap
it is 6:05 we just finished our last
shot we have to be out by 6:30 on the
dot or it's literally hundreds of
dollars on top of the building
today when I would say 85% well and the
reason why I say 85% well is because our
rap time it's that's not to say we
didn't make our day we got everything we
needed
if your cars backed up
Scout's all right maybe better than how
you found it